what's up with Hopsin I see him running
around with his Iggy Azalea honest yeah
yeah yeah yeah seems like a bipolar guy
yeah he's kind of on and off about
hip-hop yeah man I don't know how he
truly feels about his love for hip-hop
but I know that hot loves the rack he's
great rapper anything and he's in a
lovey-dovey place right now you know and
I just like to see him happy though
right Hopsin fans can be angry they can
they they they can be angry sometimes
and I feel like he gets caught up in
that so I like to see him happy do your
thang skate chill with your girl and
come back and bust a hey you know I'm
saying so he say working on his new
project that's the word that I just got
that's dope and small one say nothing
about it cuz I don't know nothing about
it but he's working he's coming that's
what about swiss swiss his weapon was
working i'm still waiting on Swizz to be
final with us cuz it starts with swizz
and then it comes to us and then we
allowed to you know brag about it and be
hype about it but he say coming he say
he got that [__] I mean I think out of
the whole label are you closest with
Jerry anything um my little hole label
closest what hoppa what hoppa well-being
it happens to home yeah hopper hopper
but as the artist um I don't know I'm
equally cuz when I kick it with him we
all like kick it like but other than
that Gerrans in Atlanta and swishes I
won't spread out every yeah but when I'm
with swizz we have some of the deepest
conversations when I'm with hot we
always laugh and fun jared is crazy so
in a footrace in each other yeah and
then jaron is probably talking about
porn or some [__] always we always have
my something crazy yeah that's the sup
man dizzy Wright get him on the
Instagram get everybody your info where
they can go download all the mixtapes
and no definitely man itunes man does he
write youtube dizzy Wright Facebook
dizzy Wright Twitter dizzy Wright
Instagram dizzy hippie with a why I let
you koala man i'm out here world peace